la comunidad internacional sigue con la
retirada de los suyos de afganistán este
martes en aviones como este del ejército
francés los vuelos retomaron en la
capital afgana después del caos del
lunes bajo control estadounidense la
terminal se ha convertido en la
esperanza de miles de personas para
abandonar un país que vuelve a estar
bajo el control de la más estricta ley
islámica
640 afganos abordaron el lunes un avión
de la fuerza aérea estadounidense con
destino a qatar un reflejo del éxodo en
el país y en donde el futuro de las
mujeres sigue siendo una gran
preocupación
fuimos al aeropuerto pero regresamos
porque la situación era mala en el
aeropuerto y todo el mundo tenía miedo
de una llegada sorpresiva de los
talibanes
mientras tanto los insurgentes avanzan
con su control sobre kabul el talibán
anunció este martes una amnistía para
aquellos que trabajaron en el anterior
gobierno y dicen animar la presencia de
mujeres en su administración pese a que
defienden la aplicación de la 'sharia'
la cual atenta contra los derechos del
sexo femenino desde la onu ponen en duda
estas promesas de ser women dicen que
las mujeres puede trabajar y que las
niñas pueden ir a la escuela tales
compromisos necesitan ser honrados y de
momento teniendo en cuenta el pasado
estas declaraciones son recibidas con
algo de escepticismo
pese a la toma de los talibanes en
afganistán el presidente estadounidense
joe biden defiende esta retirada que
según lo planeado debe completarse para
final de mes después de dos décadas de
intervención